bonjour bienvenue sur l'émission minut
forme donc aujourd'hui on est avec
Alison Alison ça va ça va donc Alisson
aujourd'hui va travailler un petit peu
le haut du corps ok donc le mouvement de
base pour travailler le haut du corps
reste les ponts donc là on va voir
comment justement avec les p travailler
sur la silhouette donc l'épaule très
important de garder les épaules en
arrière donc à chaque fois que tu vas
descendre dans le mouvement tu vas
inspirer en ouvrant la cach ici voilà
voilà en poussant les épaules vers
l'arrière et en sou voilà mais on essaie
de garder tout le temps les épaules vers
l'arrière ok donc le ventre pareil donc
quand on va expirer on va rentrer le
ventre et même quand on va relâcher on
va essayer de garder quand même la
contraction ok donc on va voir les
pompes donc on se met en position là on
tend bien les bras ok on sort la
poitrine et on inspire les épaules en
arr
et on descend au niveau du coude ici
voil et la drit on inspire et on
exp on inspire on expire on t bien les
bras pour contter bien l'arrière du bras
en haut du voilà on sort la poitrine les
abdos bien rentrés et on souff inspire
expire les pompes 10 à 20 répétitions 3
à 5 séries quotidiennement pour ne pas
forcer sur les épaules gardez le dos
bien droit afin de ne pas forcer sur les
poignets équilibrer votre
poids